Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die die Sabende Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das Erzgespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das ordentlich für Sie?
Ja, ist ordentlich.
Was sagt ihr?
So als würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, mein Name ist Hans Müller.
Hans Müller.
Frau Müller, können Sie Ihren Namen auf die Fahne geben?
Ja, ich bin nicht Frau Doktor, Hans Müller.
Ja.
Ok, danke schön, Herr Müller. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 65.
Ok, und wann sind Sie geboren?
1. Juli 1960.
1960, ok. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 87 groß. 1 Meter 87.
87, ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege 67 Kilogramm.
67, ok. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Ja, mein Hausarzt heißt Wolfgang Stark.
Wolfgang Stark.
Gang.
Ja, Gang Stark.
Ok, Herr Wolfgang Stark.
Ja, Herr Wolfgang Stark, ja.
Ok, danke schön für diese Information, Herr Müller.
Und was kann ich, was für Sie heute so ist? Was kann ich mit?
Ja, Frau Doktor, habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Ehrlich zu sagen, es ist in letzter Zeit schlimm geworden.
Normalerweise hatte ich seit 3 Monaten Bauchschmerzen.
In der letzten 1 oder 2 Wochen sind meine Schmerzen schlimm geworden.
Deswegen möchte ich hierher kommen.
Ok, Herr Müller, wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Meine Schmerzen sind im Unterbauch, manchmal linksseitig.
Ich kann es nicht ganz genau beschreiben, aber im Unterbauch, im Mittelbauch, linksseitig habe ich Schmerzen.
Ok, Unterbauch. Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Manchmal fühle ich im Ganzbauch Schmerzen, aber nur im Bauch.
Ok, haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, ja, habe Schmerzen jetzt.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10?
Ein ist leicht, ein ist sehr stark, Schmerzen ist fried.
Jetzt oder am Anfang? Jetzt. Jetzt vielleicht 5 oder 6, manchmal 7, aber jetzt 5.
Am Anfang hatte ich vielleicht 2 oder 3 Schmerzen, aber im Verlauf sind meine Schmerzen schlimm geworden.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Gespräch aufhalten oder brauchen Sie sofort ein Schmerzmittel?
Nein, ich brauche nicht, Frau Doktor, ich habe seit 3 Monaten Schmerzen, deswegen kann ich erhalten.
Ok, haben Sie ein Schmerzmittel für diese Beschwerden angenommen? Zu Hause angenommen?
Nein, nein, das habe ich nicht angenommen.
Ok, können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben? Sind diese Schmerzen druckend, stähend, dunf oder kolikartig, krampfartig?
Ja, ich habe manchmal Krampf, krampfartige Schmerzen habe ich.
Manchmal kommen, manchmal gehen, nicht immer, aber das ist wie Atakartig, kann ich sagen.
Meinen Sie velenformig oder? Nein, Atak.
Ja, manchmal schlimm, manchmal besser, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Wie lange dauert es? Wie viel?
Manchmal habe ich halbe Stunde Schmerzen, manchmal eine Stunde, aber es kommt und geht.
Denken Sie, es gibt eine Beschwerde, die Schmerzen gibt?
Bewebung, Belastung, Ernährung, SNS?
Ja, seit drei Monaten habe ich Schmerzen, erste Schmerzen, Sie möchten wissen.
Ich habe ein sehr schweres Abendessen gegessen, mit Fettiges.
Nach dem fettigen Abendessen habe ich meine Schmerzen angefangen, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es mit Essen verbunden hat oder nicht.
Ich habe seit drei Monaten Schmerzen.
Sind diese Schmerzen gurteformig? Nein, nein, ich fühle sie nicht im Rücken.
Gibt es etwas, was Schmerzen verschlimmert oder lindert? Nein, ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Okay, haben Sie auch mit diesen Schmerzen Fieber?
Ich fühle mich fieberig, aber einmal habe ich gemessen, es waren 37,5.
Nichts, vielleicht aber, ich fühle mich fieberig.
Haben Sie Schütterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Schütterfrost habe ich nicht, aber Nachschweiß habe ich manchmal.
Okay, und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab- oder so genommen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, normalerweise esse ich sehr gut, aber seit zwei oder drei Monaten habe ich keinen Appetit.
Besonders seit zwei oder drei Wochen habe ich keinen Appetit.
Deswegen habe ich unwillkürlich 6 Kilo abgenommen.
Normalerweise war ich über 70, aber jetzt bin ich 67.
Okay, ist Ihnen üben?
Manchmal fühle ich mich übergessig.
Okay, haben Sie Erbrüche?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie für diese Beschwerden andere Arschdienste?
Ja, Frau Doktor, letzte Monate habe ich mein Hausarzt besucht und er hat mir empfohlen nach dem Krankenhaus zu gehen.
Okay, hat er Ihnen eine Medikamente verschieben?
Nein, nein, er hat mir nur empfohlen nach dem Krankenhaus zu gehen.
Okay, haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, aber haben Sie einige Verdankensprobleme?
Z.B. Zotbrünen, Sauerstoff oder fühlen Sie sich voller Gefühl?
Ja, vor zwei Wochen fühle ich mich voller Gefühl, aber Zotbrünen habe ich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Gehen Sie jeden Tag auf die Toilette?
Ja, manchmal habe ich Durchfall, manchmal habe ich Verstopfung.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was passiert ist.
Einmal habe ich gemerkt, dass mein Stuhl dunkelrot war.
Einmal habe ich gemerkt, dass es hellrot war.
Ich habe Blutbemischung gemerkt.
Manchmal habe ich Blutbemischung, manchmal Durchfall.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert ist.
Okay, haben Sie jetzt Durchfall?
Jetzt habe ich Durchfall.
Wie oft gehen Sie in die Toilette?
In der letzten Woche gehe ich 3-mal pro Tag.
Mein Stuhl ist weich und manchmal habe ich hellrot Blutbemischung gemerkt.
Okay, Sie haben Blut im Stuhl gemerkt?
Ja, ja.
Ich habe Angst, Blut.
Ich hatte Angst, Blut.
Deswegen habe ich meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Er hat mir sofort empfohlen, ein Krankenhaus zu besuchen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Sie sind in gutem Halt.
Wir werden Ihnen schnell helfen.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir werden alle Notizen und Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Frau Doktor, ich habe viele verschiedene Erkrankungen.
Ich leide an chronischen Lungenentzündungen seit 20 Jahren.
Manchmal huste ich.
Jetzt huste ich nicht, aber normalerweise.
Ich habe chronische Hüsten.
Manchmal nutze ich einen Spray.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Name ist.
Manchmal nehme ich einen Spray.
Ich leide auch seit 10 Jahren an Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit 15 Jahren habe ich Bluthochdruck.
Sie haben mir gefragt, aber ich habe vergessen zu sagen.
Ich besuche sehr oft zum Wasserlassen.
Manchmal besuche ich 3-mal in der Nacht.
Und auch sehr oft tagsüber.
Ich habe seit 7 Jahren meine Vorstärkdrüse vergrößert.
Ich leide sehr oft an der Handweginfektion.
Letztes Jahr hatte ich 5-mal Handweginfektion.
5-mal?
5-mal, ja.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Metoprol regelmäßig.
Und ein Medikament gegen Vorstärkdrüsevergrößerung.
Tamsoleosin oder etwas.
Ich erinnere mich nicht ganz genau.
Tablet?
Ja, Tamsoleosin Tablet, vielleicht 4 mg.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung Metoprolol?
Ja, 50 mg oder so.
Aber einmal morgens nehme ich.
Und Tamsoleosin einmal abends.
Abends, ok.
Vor dem Schlafen.
Ok. Noch etwas? Metoprolol, Tamsoleosin und noch andere?
Ja, manchmal nehme ich einen Spray.
Aber ich weiß nicht den Namen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Alles.
Alles, ok.
Würdet ihr schon einmal operiert?
Ja, vor 17 Jahren meine Galenblase wurde entfernt.
Galenblase?
Ja.
Wissen Sie die Ursache?
Galenstein oder Entzündung?
Galenstein, ich denke Galenstein hatte ich.
Ok. Noch etwas?
Ja, noch etwas. Das ist sehr viel, Frau Doktor.
Was kann ich noch haben?
Rauen Sie Hermine?
Ja, ich rauche gerne, Frau Doktor.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit 30 Jahren rauche ich eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Eine Schachtel, ok.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, am Morgen manchmal zwei oder drei Gläser Bier trinke ich.
Glas oder Flasche?
Glas.
Bier, ok.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Das ist eine rhythmäzige Frage.
Ja, das ist eine sehr lange Geschichte, Frau Doktor.
Als ich im Gymnasium war, hatte ich dreimal Joint geraucht, aber nur im Gymnasium.
Ok. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schreinerei, Frau Doktor.
Schreinerei, ok.
Meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig.
Ok. Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja. Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja. Meine Kinder sind erwachsen.
Eins ist 40, eins ist 35.
Ok. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ok. Sind Sie vollständig, Kind?
Ja, ja.
Ok. Haben Sie irgendwelche bekannten Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich esse alles. Ich habe keine Allergie.
Keine Medikamente, Lebensmittel, keine Allergie.
Nein, nein. Ich weiß nicht, nein.
Ok. Waren Sie in Lisezayt im Ausland?
Letztes Jahr war ich in Spanien.
Ok. Ich möchte fragen, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Bei Vater oder bei Mutter?
Ja, leider ist mein Vater an Darmkrebs gestorben, Frau Doktor.
Er war 70 und ich bin 65.
Er ist an Darmkrebs gestorben, deswegen habe ich Angst.
Kann ich Krebs haben, Frau Doktor? Darmkrebs haben? Oder?
Ja, wir schauen.
Ist das möglich oder?
Ja, natürlich ist das möglich. Aber jetzt haben wir keine Gründe für Angst.
Wir müssen einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich habe bei der Mutter recherchiert. Blut im Stuhl spricht für Darmkrebs.
Ich hatte Angst. Ich kann seit zwei Wochen nicht schlafen.
Ja, Krebs kann sein. Aber das kann eine Gastroenteritis sein.
Oder eine Entzündung. Deshalb machen Sie bitte keine Sorgen.
Ich fühle mich besser jetzt. Danke, Frau Doktor.
Hat Ihre Mutter irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter ist sehr gesund wie Stein.
Ok. Sehr, sehr gut. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Hat er eine Erkrankung?
Er leidet auf Bluthochdruck und Blutzuckerkrankheit.
Ich weiß nicht, viele verschiedene Krankheiten hat er.
Ok, Herr Müller. Ich möchte fragen, haben Sie eine Durchgefühl im Bauch bemerkt?
Eine Schwellung oder eine Durchgefühl in der linken oder rechten Seite.
Manchmal habe ich Blähungen. Deswegen fühle ich ein bisschen Schwellung. Aber ich weiß nicht.
Ok, ich verstehe. Danke.
Was meinen Sie mit Durchgefühl?
Durchgefühl? Ich weiß nicht.
Druckgefühl.
Ok, ich habe Druckgefühl. Nein, ich habe kein Druckgefühl.
Ok, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen, Herr Müller. Möchten Sie noch etwas entschuldigen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Was kann ich vermutlich haben? Frau Doktor, ich frage mich darauf.
Herr Müller, ich verstehe Sie.
Ich möchte Ihnen schnell eine Antwort geben. Aber Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben.
Ich möchte Sie kurz aufrufen und eine deutliche Diagnose stellen.
Um eine deutliche Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
So erst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen und einige operative Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen. Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen ein Genres sagen.
Ich möchte Sie bitte noch ein wenig Geduld haben.
Ok, Frau Doktor. Ich fühle mich besser jetzt. Ich danke Ihnen.
Bitte gehen Sie in den Behandlungszimmer und ich werde gleich zu Ihnen kommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient heißt Hans Müller, er ist 65 Jahre alt, er ist 1,87 Meter groß und er ist 60 Kilogramm schwer.
Er ist seit drei Monaten bei uns. Er ist ein guter Patient.
Er ist ein guter Patient. Er ist ein guter Patient.
Der Schmerzen würde nicht ausfallen.
Der Patient berichtete keine bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen.
Der Patient, Herr Müller, hat für diese Beschwerden seine Hausarzt besucht.
Aber er würde den Patienten überwiesen.
Der Patient berichtet über den Fieber, Nachschweiß und einen Gewichtverlust von 6 Kilogramm innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Der Patient hat jetzt einen Durchfall mit Blut. Der Patient ist jetzt Melena.
Melena oder?
Hematomez. Nein.
Er ist ein guter Patient. Er ist ein guter Patient. Er ist ein guter Patient.
Er hat eine chronische Obstruktur und eine Lungenerkrankung.
Seit zehn Jahren ein Reisdarm-Syndrom und seit fünfzehn Jahren ein Arterie-Leparton.
Er hat eine Hyperplasie.
Der Patient nimmt regelmäßig 15 Milligramm Metaprolol.
Er nimmt morgens ein Tamso-Losin-Tablet mit fünf Milligramm.
Der Patient benutzt einen Spray gegen COPD.
Aber der Name des Sprays sollte geklärt werden.
Er braucht seit 30 Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Und er trinkt am Wochenende zwei bis drei Glas von Drogen.
Der Patient hat als Jugend dreimal ausprobiert.
Er ist Schreiner. Er arbeitet als Schreiner. Er ist verheiratet. Er hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er ist vollständig geimpft. Er hat keine bekannten Allergien.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben, dass ihr Vater an Kolonkars-Syndrom verstorben ist.
Seine Mutter ist gesund.
Er hat einen Bruder. Er leidet an Arterie-Leparton und Diabetes Meletus.
Er hat bei den Patienten vor 17 Jahren eine Cholesthektomie auf Grundstein durchgeführt.
Die Anamnistischen angaben uns an Ehesten auf eine Analyse.
Als differential Diagnosen kommen Divertikulitis, chronisch entzündliche Darmerkrankungen, Reisdarm-Syndrom,
in Betracht.
Sollte in Betracht zur Abklärung der Beschwerden sollten...
Welche Symptome sprechen für einen Kolonkarzinom?
Der Patient hat seit drei Monaten hypogastrische Schmerzen mit Diarrhea und Obstipation.
Er hat Nachtschweiß und Gewichtverlust.
Welchen Begriff können wir hier für Nachtschweiß benutzen?
Nachtschweiß?
Nichts wie Hypohydrosin.
Er hat erbliche Wiskfaktoren.
Sein Vater hat Kolonkarzinom.
Welche Symptome sprechen für einen Kolonkarzinom?
Zur Abklärung der Beschwerden werde ich die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es eine Loslassschmerzen, Aufwärtsspannung und Druckschmerzen gibt.
Welche Hautveränderung erwarten Sie bei diesem Patienten?
Ich erwarte normalerweise keine Befunde, aber wir können sehr gut oder nicht.
Ich habe keine Befunde.
Der Patient hat Kolonprobleme?
Besonders Blutung? Was erwarten Sie?
Der Haut kann kalt und blase sein.
Was ist der Fachbegriff?
Animi?
Palo. Palo können wir feststellen.
Ich bin aus der Kultur ganz abenteuerlich.
Ich kann die Färmerte darmgeräusche feststellen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen und einige Laborparameter überprüfen.
Ich werde die Blutbilder, die Entzündungsparameter, die Elektrolytos, die Nieren und die Lebewerte und einige Tumormarken für die Kalonkarzinom bestimmen lassen.
Ich möchte diese Patienten digital rektieren.
Dann würde ich eine Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen und gegebenenfalls eine CT-Tomographie des Abdomens veranlassen.
Warum würden Sie eine Sonographie durchführen?
Die Sonographie ist eine Abdomen-Sonographie.
Ich möchte eine Sonographie durchführen, um andere Abdomen-Patologien auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich eine Sonographie durchführen, um andere Abdomen-Patologien auszuschließen.
Machen Sie weiter.
Dann würde ich eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Dann würde ich diese Patienten eine Koloskopie durchführen lassen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Zuerst würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen und alle vitalen Parameter überwachen und eine Venöse zuganglegen und eine Schmerzmittel und ausreichende Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Dann würde ich eine gastroenterologische oder chirurgische Konstellanzung anfordern.
Wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt wird, würde ich eine Operation planen.
So sollten wir das Studium bestätigen.
Dann machen wir unsere Behandlung planen.
Können Sie bitte die Computertomographie aufklären?
Die Computertomographie ist eine Untersuchung und eine Methode, um alle inneren Organe zu beurteilen.
Mit Hilfe der Computertomographie können wir Blutung oder Tumoren beurteilen.
Das ist eine Schmerzfreie Untersuchung.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Hans Müller ist ein 56-jähriger Patient.
Er wurde am 1.7.1960 geboren.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund der bestehenden, prognodierten Wellen von Müller Bauchschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 bis 6 von 10 bewertet.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über Blattulenz, Meteorismus.
Die Frage nach Husten, Atemnot, Pirosis wurde verneint.
Er teilte mit, dass die Schmerzen im ganzen Bauch sind.
In der vegetativen Anamnese fanden sich Fieber, nachtliche Hyperhydros, Appetitlosigkeit, Gewichtabnahme, 6 kg, Neusea und Diabe und Obstipation.
Darüber hinaus klagte er einmal Hämotokese.
In der Familienanvorerkrankung fanden sich COPD seit 20 Jahren, Reisdarmzentrum seit 10 Jahren, arterielle Hypertonie seit 15 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er Methylfolol einmal morgens ein.
Die Dosis ist nicht erinnerlich.
So wie Beninprostate, Hypopilosin, dagegen nimmt er Tamtylosin 4 mg ein.
Er leidet an regelmäßiger Handwegentzündung.
Vor 15 Jahren wurde ihm eine Cholelytiasis, eine Cholesystektomie, durchgeführt.
Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten sind nicht bekannt.
Er rauche seit 30 Jahren eine Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinkt 2 bis 3 Gläser Bier pro Woche.
Er hat Drei-mal-Joint-Drogen konsumiert.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er hat zwei gesunde Sohne.
In der Familienanamnese fanden sich bei dem Vater Darmkrebs.
Er ist mit 70 Jahren daran gestorben.
Bei dem Bruder arterielle Hypertonie und Diabetes mellitus.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet auf Koloncarcinom,
Differenziell diagnostisch kommend, Magencarcinom,
chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankung, Colitis ulcerosa.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst vital Parameter messen.
Danach den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und oskultieren.
Bei der Koloncarcinom ist insbesondere die Palpation entscheidend.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich eine Blutuntersuchung durchführen,
um Blutbild, Chorio-Carcinomebryogenikantigen und Lebewerte und Entzündungswerte zu bestimmen.
Als operativer Diagnostik würde ich die Abdomengraphie und Sonographie und Koloskopie durchführen.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Koloncarcinom bei diesen Patienten?
Dafür spricht Hämatokese, Gewichtabnahme und Bauchschmerzen.
Gibt es andere Risikofaktoren bei diesen Patienten?
Der Herr Oberast spricht von einem Darmkrebs.
Also eine familiäre Diskozystierung.
Ja, die Koloncarcinom verstorben.
Genetische Veranlagung spricht für Koloncarcinom.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Abdomenar-Sonographie durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie bei dieser Untersuchung?
Bei der Sonographie erwarte ich, dass wir Tumorgewebe darstellen können.
Auch wir können die anderen Abdomen-Pathologen ausschließen.
Können Sie bitte die Ultrasonographie aufklären?
Die Ultrasonographie ist eine schmerzlose Therapie.
Wir können besonders weiches Gewebe darstellen.
Besonders nutzen wir den Bauch, den Leber, um Milch darzustellen.
Wie lange dauert diese Untersuchung?
In der Regel dauert es 5-10 Minuten.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Labouruntersuchung?
Bei der Labouruntersuchung erwarte ich niedrige Hemoglobinwerte wegen des Hämatokeses.
Und auch eine vermehrte Choreo-Emyrogenik-Antigen-Erhöhung.
Sie haben schon die körperliche Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Auch die Labor- und operative Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie denn?
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen?
Ja, sollte sich der Verdacht auf einen Kolonkarzinom bestätigen.
Würde ich operative Therapie empfehlen, wenn es möglich ist.
Würde ich den Patienten in eine chirurgische Konzertsitzung durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls eine Agitator- oder Neu-Agentherapie empfehlen.
Würden Sie den Patienten ambulant oder stationär behandeln?
Ich würde den Patienten stationär behandeln.
Ok.
Dann kann ich auch eine andere Aufklärung fragen.
Könnten Sie bitte Koloskopie aufklären?
Koloskopie ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Maßnahme, sondern auch eine therapeutische Maßnahme.
Wir nutzen sie wie ein Schlauch.
Es wird durchdurch eingeführt.
Wir können die Diktarm- und Terminaliläum darstellen.
Und wie gesagt können wir Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Das ist eine Schmerzhaftige Therapie.
Deswegen können wir leichte Narkose geben.
Bei der Untersuchung.
Benötigt der Patient eine spezielle Vorbereitung für die Untersuchung?
Ja, es dauert in der Regel drei Tage.
Der Patient sollte am Anfang nur mit Flüssigkeit ernähren.
Ok. Also der Patient benötigt eine spezielle Reinigung?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ok. Gut.
Na gut.
Wir müssen jetzt erst mal.